[MUSIC]
Around 2,500 years ago, a
group of revolutionary thinkers
changed the way we
think about mathematics.
Through the idea of
proof, the ancient Greeks
showed that maths isn't just
about performing calculations,
but a way of
understanding and testing
the reality of the
world around us.
The sign above
Plato's Academy was
said to have read: let no
one ignorant of geometry
enter here.
And the great Archimedes
was even killed by a soldier
because he refused to
leave a proof unfinished.
But, what is a proof?
Simply put, a proof is
a convincing argument
to demonstrate whether
something is true or false.
For example, if all dogs have
four legs, then: is this a dog?
It's easy to prove that just
because all dogs have four
legs, not everything
with four legs is a dog.
How about a mathematical proof?
You've probably heard
of Pythagoras's theorem,
a mathematical fact
about the sides
of a right-angled triangle.
Here's one demonstration
of the theorem.
Does it convince you?
Good proofs are undeniably true.
200 years after
Pythagoras was around,
another Greek
mathematician called
Euclid perfected the
way to write proofs.
With just a few basic
assumptions known as axioms,
Euclid was able to prove many
other mathematical results.
He compiled these results into
one remarkable book called
The Elements, and his
proofs are as true today as
when it was first
written and have
formed the foundations
of modern mathematics.
From proofs about infinite
prime numbers used
internet encryption to
mathematical formulae used
in engineering,
the ancient Greeks
have provided scientists,
economists, lawyers,
architects, and well,
just about everyone,
with a new mathematical
understanding of our world.
[MUSIC]